[Music]
yeah elon's got this great quote where
he says
no dude he's been going off on twitter
lately dawg
dude he's been going off on twitter have
you seen his twitter recently so good
he's dunking on all these trolls dude
so sick he posted this meme about like
the political spectrum and all these
[ __ ] normies got so upset did you see
him dunk on aoc
yeah dude
he dunked on her
okay i mean like so we called it last
time obviously every single comment was
cody [ __ ] slobbing on elon's knob and
i think most of them were jokes but like
i like to have conversations like that
because i like to understand both sides
of things yeah yeah it's fair right yeah
and so i thought this was kind of can
you zoom in on that at all he's
obviously a vision this is kara swisher
by the way there's like a tech
journalist she's been around for [ __ ]
ever she's interviewed him multiple
times she knows everything there is to
know about him i'm pretty sure right
yeah
so this is a quote read it uh he's
obviously a visionary she's not british
oh he's obviously a visionary
i prefer dealing with him to others
because he gives you genuine answers he
will call you back he will have a beef
with you when others run away because
they're cowardly if he disagrees he'll
be in your face but at least he's in
your face i'm perfectly fine with that
uh in a world where everybody's making a
lot of silly stuff he's not
cars rockets solar these are important
things he can't be as silly or as
fascist as people make him out to be
maybe he does act like a stupid tech bro
sometimes
but maybe he's a little more complex
than that thomas edison was not a nice
man many inventors were difficult
problematic people steve jobs for
example
the times we live in are so reductive
that it's really hard to be able to get
our minds around a truly complex human
being and that's what he is so i thought
that was interesting right that's
relevant to what we were talking about
last time yeah
yeah
yeah
uh i still think he just is
john mcafee pretending to be
an inventor
that's that that's my problem she's like
oh many inventors were difficult he's
he's not an inventor no but think about
the amount of things that have happened
again like i don't know [ __ ] like
even edison edison was a patent guy but
go ahead yeah okay that's fair
but that's still like a lot of things
wouldn't
wouldn't have happened if it weren't for
him right sort of i think people put
forward the argument that things would
have happened but he like had the money
and like kind of like snatched it all up
for himself he was enterprising because
i'm like
if he just owned that like i'm john
mcafee but it's that it's that
layer on top where he's like trying to
be a cool person it's just like
[ __ ] you yeah
i just can't give it to him i just can't
yeah because this is someone everyone
would have bullied in high school yeah
so no i know i know did you see him at
the [ __ ] met gal yesterday oh yeah
doing this little oh my god
nine-year-old dancer just yeah
jesus christ
yeah um
i think that's the you know and and and
i'm fully jealous because um
i've never been trending on twitter
i don't know one time but you know this
guy trends all the time
for being an [ __ ] you know it's i'm
i'm jealous of him
um
but i hate that this dude just gets like
paraded around
as like the tech jesus yeah when we have
a real god we should be praying to who
is
steve jobs uh steve jobs yup
jack dorsey yes yeah real real tech
jesus
who actually made the apple one
wozniak oh yeah
yeah wozniack
yeah see like we don't give a [ __ ] about
that dude
i do
yeah cause i like him
he's a g
cause we're he's an ultimate chiller
because he was dancing with the stars a
few years ago and it was absolutely
tragic yeah why what happened what did
he do see that that's how society that's
how much society doesn't care about this
dude we put this dude on dancing with
the stars that's a dick movie yeah that
really is a dick move
oh no can uh pull up a video clip you
have to that's a dick move this guy made
computers his whole life he wrote code
like why would he opt into this though
because he's like i just want some
recognition yeah he wants to be accepted
for something
play some music dude we're in the bone
bro
[Music]
okay
okay
all right waz get it man yeah
just eat [ __ ] dumbass yeah that was a
possibility
[Music]
okay look look look the footwork is not
bad he's killing it
[Music]
izzy though
[Music]
bro
dude i feel like i'm watching like
i feel like i'm watching like a
a waiter at sonic deliver like 100
drinks on a tray
down a long alleyway like when is this
gonna go bad
oh whoa whoa look at that
hot on the feet man
man you saw a supreme focus in his eyes
yeah yeah he's like i cannot dude that
was pretty good yeah he did all right
man let's say he kind of killed it he
did but it's still rude yeah yo let's
take the guy who like greatly influenced
technology
actually
and just make him dance yeah
i know what you mean though like they're
they're that is how and and i hate that
i'm about to say this
there are those people that like get
[ __ ] done yeah but i i hate that
there's only a handful of those people
in this world i think elon gives like
license to people who aren't those
people would be like yeah dude
i'm a visionary man yeah i am i'm
everything i'm
like could the full
you know yeah could elon do all this if
he was not born into diamond money
was he
damn being an emerald mine yeah an
emerald mine
[ __ ] this dude own [ __ ] like wizard
of oz stone
automatically ahead like
that's that is why like this to me is
like a trust fund kid being like i'm a
visionary it's like no dude you bought
up a bunch of nerds projects no no but
actually i saw kind of a good uh like
counter argument to that point today
think of all the [ __ ] rich kids that
haven't done [ __ ]
yeah
like that doesn't discredit what he's
done
saying that he was born into wealth
there's plenty of wealthy kids that just
do
percocets all day like the amount of
even his track record now yeah how could
you credit that to being born into
wealth like he made money off paypal
yeah that was probably what and then he
put all that money into tesla i'm pretty
sure yeah
so like
all things considered his the percentage
that his parents wealth played into his
entire
fortune now is probably nothing i guess
i don't know like yeah because because
if he got money from his parents then he
all in on paypal and then like it was a
good play it's more so i think that
people try to call him tony stark yeah
yeah no that's fair i mean i i want to
say like i don't care but then i'm like
well he's literally at the center of
this national debate now about free
speech and he's the guy sitting in the
middle it is a super interesting thing
that now he's gone from like the guy who
bought hair plugs and like paypal and
like dated grimes to like now he owns
one of the major
like intersects of like human discourse
and people are frustrated with that
because now it's just like oh
this dude is like a cult leader it's
like he's gonna [ __ ] save us and i
think that's people's pushback is yeah
yo this should not be the guy because
he's [ __ ] he's clearly like an egomaniac
yeah you're kind of dick rotting him a
little bit yeah
oh dude is that you yeah i couldn't hear
your points because you were sucking him
up all i heard is
um [ __ ] me out by elon
elon for sure is the [ __ ] tech ceo
yeah that's for sure you think so
he's a [ __ ] dude
i don't think he [ __ ] around
yeah i don't know maybe not